Well,
I think certainly one of the things I've learned,
see,
I already knew before all this happened that people were primarily conforming.
I actually don't have much of a problem with that because most of the time the
tradition is correct,
but sometimes it's not correct at all.
That's the problem is that,
so you know,
one of the things I always tell my clients and my students for that matter is
you should do what everyone else does unless you have a really good reason to
vary.
And one of the things I learned from young Carl Young was that,
and if you do very,
you should try to only do it in a couple of directions because you probably
can't handle doing it more than that.
It's just too much to too much psychologically.
But you know,
the problem is is that sometimes the group is rowing off a cliff and then it's
then you know,
that's partly why the individual in some senses the eternal savior of the group
because the group has,
it has the aspect of sheep,
let's say,
and the sheep are doing fine.
They've got the whole herd thing going for them,
decreases the risk of individual predation.
They've got all their nervous systems in tune.
So there's real utility in the herd,
but they're also subject to all the problems that herds have like heard panic
and so,
so that's not good enough.
That's what human beings figured out was that being part of the herd,
although necessary,
isn't good enough.
There has to be a balance between the tradition,
the old dead tradition and the river vivifying force of the,
of the law of the living.
Essentially that's,
those are actually how the gods split up and need you.
Because Horace was roughly a representation of the living and oh,
Cyrus was roughly a representation of the dead and it was the combined
combination of those two that made up the sovereign very intelligent,
like dramatic political philosophy.
So,
but you know,
one of the things I have seen since September is,
I mean,
I knew that people were conformance,
but I really had,
I really had no idea to what degree that was true.
You know,
like,
I mean I've got ver very,
very few letters of support from people who are academics for example.
And they,
I get secret reports really.
You know,
people will come and say,
well,
we agree with what you're doing,
but we wish you could be a little nicer about it.
Which,
which we know it's a funny thing for people to say because it implies that if
they did what I was doing,
they would do a better job,
you know,
in which is fine,
but you know,
you can always try it out and see how it goes.
So when I gave talks,
equity,
one of the most common comments I would get after the thing's over and people
are finally,
I agree with everything you said,
I would never,
yeah,
yeah.
Well it's no wonder it's,
no,
it's not surprising,
you know?
I mean,
there are real reasons not to stick out from the herd.
If,
if you,
if you mark a zebra so that you can identify it against the herd,
the lions will kill it.
Right.
And that's that.
Then I tell you,
no one that you like that because they can't,
they can't organize their haunted less.
They can identify the individual
that's right.
While they're,
they're camouflaged against the herd zebras.
So that's,
man,
that's worth knowing.
It explains a lot that.